d'un pas décidé
ces manifestants se ruent à l'intérieur
du théâtre des bouffes du nord
prenons par surprise des policiers
déployés devant l'établissement culturel
leur objectif perturbé la virée nocturne
du président alors qu emmanuel macron et
son épouse assiste à une représentation
théâtrale la tentative d'intrusion a
très vite été maîtrisé
le chef de l'état sécurisé à l'intérieur
du théâtre pendant quelques minutes une
présence révélé quelques instants plus
tôt par le journaliste et militante à
abu hafs assis quelques rangées derrière
le président je suis actuellement au
théâtre des bouffes du nord métro la
chapelle trois rangées derrière le
président de la république
des militants sont quelque part dans le
coin et appelle tout le monde à
rappliquer quelque chose se prépare la
soirée risque d'être mouvementée selon
des sources judiciaires
le journaliste a ensuite été interpellé
et conduit au commissariat
taha boivent c'est suspecté par la
police et des proches du président
d'être à l'origine de ce rassemblement
l'opposition elle condamne fermement
cette arrestation
dans quels régimes sommes-nous pour
qu'un président furieux que des
manifestants conspuaient à l'extérieur
d'un théâtre fasse arrêter un
journaliste qui s'y trouvait et qui
avait osé communiquer sur sa présence le
président de la république
exfiltré goutal impopularité en pleine
capitale
faute de pouvoir argumenter ils exigent
la répression et l'arrestation d'un
journaliste
de l'autre côté le groupe la république
en marche condamne fermement la
tentative d'intrusion dans le théâtre
les auteurs de ces agressions sèment la
violence et la discorde
nous les ferons reculer par le
rassemblement des français et la
solidarité
le président de la république est resté
jusqu'à la fin de la représentation aux
bouffes du nord
il n'a en aucun cas été exfiltré le
militant ta aboaf a été interpellé et
qu'on ne parle pas de journaliste en ce
45e jour de grève
plusieurs autres actions ciblées ont été
menées hier par les opposants à la
réforme des retraites l'elysée affirme
que le président continuera à se rendre
à des représentations théâtrales et
condamne toute tentative d'intimidation
[Musique]